[MUSIC PLAYING]
JUSTIN BROUGHTON: All
right, are we ready?
Yes?
All right.
Testing Games in the Cloud.
Welcome, I am Justin.
I'm an engineering
manager at Google.
And today, we're going
to talk about testing
mobile games in the Cloud.
So hopefully, all
of you have seen
the what we're
calling a Dory, which
was on the previous slide.
Also, there's a link
in the Session page
for this session in the app.
And with that, you
can ask questions
if you haven't been
to a session before.
You can actually ask questions.
During this presentation,
you can ask questions there,
and we will have plenty of
time for questions at the end.
In fact, I'd even like to
open up to a little bit more
than perhaps questions.
So maybe, understand a little
bit more about your experiences
with testing of games.
But we'll get there.
So let's start by asking
the question, when
we test apps and games,
what are we looking for?
Well in some respects, games
are just like applications.
So we're looking
for signals that
might indicate a problem
or a bad experience,
such as slow startup time.
Of course, we're also
looking for crashes
or not responding events,
which give a particularly
bad experience to the user.
We're also looking for
incorrect behavior, where
the game does not
behave as we intend
or indeed as the user expects.
But with games, we
care very specifically
about a number of things.
One of these is incorrect
or slow rendering.
That is because games provide
an immersive experience--
an immersive experience
which is thoroughly ruined
if your UI is janky or slow.
So what are games companies
doing today around testing?
Well, I've talked with
perhaps many of you
and certainly a lot
of games companies.
And there's a whole hell of a
lot of manual testing going on.
That is, manual testing
before you release,
and then releasing
to a whole bunch
of alpha or beta customers
for a bit of free testing.
There is some-- not a lot--
there is some test automation.
But it's usually
homegrown, which
means it's specific to the
perhaps proprietary game
engine you're using,
or to the company
that you've built it in.
So it's not widely applicable.
It's not widely applicable
outside of the company in which
you work or that game engine.
Well, you might be asking,
why is this a problem?
Well, it's a problem
mostly because of expense.
You can imagine training
all of those testers
to not only play the
game, but actually
to become good at
the game-- so they
can get to the later level,
so they can find the issues
that your users are going to
find some months after you've
released it into production.
And then, you have to
manually test across
a variety of different devices,
and then verify the results--
which, of course, is
even more expensive.
And the testing has to be
repeated every time you
want to release to production.
The testing-- and
this is probably
the key part-- the testing is
also performed particularly
late in the process, which
means you've no idea which
of the myriad of changes
your developers have
made that could be
possibly causing
this particular problem.
So catching problems earlier
is just not possible.
And we all know that
catching problems earlier
makes them easier to
fix, as well as cheaper.
And lastly, there is
no safety net, which
means your game's developers,
or you as a game developer,
you don't know if the change
you're about to commit
is going to break the game
in some fundamental way.
So why are games
companies and developers
not flocking to
automated testing?
Well, it turns out that testing
games is frankly really,
really hard.
So recently, I
had surgery, which
is why I'm sort of limping
around on stage here.
And I spent a lot
of time lying in bed
and did what might some might
call research, which involved
playing a whole bunch of games.
Now, I don't actually
play games that often.
But in bed, I was able to
play quite a few games.
I also, during the
playing of these games--
hence the research part--
was thinking a lot about
how to test these games
and how hard it is
to test these games.
So why is it hard?
Well, firstly,
games are rendered
with something like OpenGL,
or one of the newer frameworks
like Vulkan, which makes
them really hard to test
because none of the
existing testing
frameworks that you might use
for testing applications will
work like UI Automator,
or EXI Test, or Espresso.
So these traditional
tools don't work.
But also, games offer a huge
array of possible inputs.
You can imagine playing a game
like Clash of Clans or World
of Warcraft.
And you're able to move that
character pretty much anywhere
on the screen, or build
that tower in the corner,
or in the middle, or whatever.
So essentially, the
number of interactions
you can have with a game
is virtually infinite.
And games are often
deliberately unpredictable,
which means that they give
a different experience
to the user every time.
But that means, they give
a different experience
to the test every time,
which makes it very hard
to write an automated test.
And lastly, issues
are harder to reach.
Often, you have to get to
some of the later levels
to actually find a
particular issue.
You can imagine that
your ogre on level
10, your favorite ogre,
has suddenly died,
and you have no idea why.
Now up until quite recently, the
only generally available option
for testing mobile Apple
games was Monkey Testing.
And if anybody
has had experience
with Monkey Testing,
especially of games,
you'll know it's not
particularly helpful.
Rarely does it get
very far into the game
to be particularly useful.
And also, it doesn't exercise
the game as a user would.
So you may not even care
about the issues it finds.
It's probably good at finding
crashes or issues at startup,
but really not much more.
So before we get
into actually talking
about the solutions, the
specific solutions for testing
mobile games in
the Cloud, I need
to first introduce our Cloud
testing platform, which
is Firebase Test Lab.
This is actually
something that I
have been working on at Google
for about five years now.
Firebase Test Lab
is part of the suite
of application quality products
within the Firebase umbrella.
It allows you to test your
app or game in the Cloud
across a variety of
different devices,
including, most importantly,
some high-end gaming
devices on iOS, on Android,
on physical devices,
as well as virtual devices.
You can test in
different languages.
And you can test in different
screen orientations.
And with the comprehensive
test results that you get,
you have screenshots and video
and then the most important
part-- performance
metrics, as we
talked about earlier, such as
startup time, and specifically
for games frames per second, as
well as CPU, memory, network,
and so on.
Importantly, these metrics are
synchronized with the video,
so that you can tell when your
video is displaying, whatever's
happening in your game.
You can tell what's happening
within performance metrics
and vise versa.
So you get some context into
whatever problem there is.
Also, you get crashes, not
responding events, logs,
and much, much more.
Firebase Test Lab is also--
and this is
surprisingly unknown--
Firebase Test Lab is also
the engine behind the Play
Pre-launch Report.
How many people here have heard
of the Play Pre-Launch Report?
How many?
1, 2-- wow, 2, OK.
So in case you don't know, which
is apparently 99% of you hear,
what the Pre-Launch Report is--
Pre-Launch Report
is a free report
that we give to developers
for simply uploading your app
or game into a testing
track within the Play Store.
It's under the Release
section within the Play
Store of your app
after you deploy it.
It tests your app or game
across about 10 devices
and gives you the same
comprehensive test results.
And did I mention it's free?
So there's really no excuse not
to at least take a look at it.
All right, so when
I mentioned I talked
to a lot of game
developers, the one thing
that I heard most often
from them is security.
We heard this from
so many of you--
that the security of the game is
your biggest concern, much more
so than, say,
application developers.
That is because a leak
of a pre-production game
would be really, really bad.
And that is why we've put a lot
of effort, put a lot of focus
around making sure that the
device on which you're testing
is completely cleaned up both
before and after your test.
So there's no possibility
of leaking the game
or seeing the results of
the game in a future test.
In most cases, we simply flash
the device between test runs.
We also perform a security check
on the submitter of the test,
as well as the
game or app itself.
And there you go.
I knew I was going to forget.
All right, so how
much does this cost?
I hear you ask.
Well, we charge you $1 an hour
for an Android virtual device,
and then $5 an hour for
a physical device, iOS
or Android.
But the key here is, we
only charge you for as long
as your test runs, which
means that if your test runs
for, say, five
minutes on a Pixel 2,
it'll cost you about $0.40.
We don't charge
you for how long it
takes to install
your application,
to pull off the results
from the device,
to post-process those
results, to ship them off
to Google Cloud Storage.
We only charge you for how
long you specify your test run.
And that's pretty
cheap, trust me.
So really, there's no
excuse not to implement
some regimen of automated
testing, which brings us
to how you might go about doing
that-- which is what you've all
been patiently waiting for
me to start talking about.
All right, so firstly
and most importantly,
you're going to want to
prepare your game for testing
in the Cloud.
You may want to create a
special version of your game,
or you can build test ability
actually into the code.
In Test Lab, we set a property
that you can test for.
You can then bracket
the code in your game
by testing with
an "if statement"
that simply tests this property.
So there are many
things that you
might want to do to make
your game more testable.
Firstly, you can
focus on the preamble.
You could remove some
or all of the preamble,
so that the tests can get
to the gameplay more easily.
You could remove some
of the log in part,
or the registration,
or something.
As I talked about
earlier, you probably
want to remove the
randomness, so that the tests
that you write are less flaky.
They see the same
board, or game,
or they can interact in
the same way every time.
You might want to start the
game at a specific level--
or load a whole bunch
of assets into the game,
so that the game looks like it's
been played for a long time.
That will allow you
to more easily test
these later levels or more
sophisticated gameplay.
And of course,
there's a lot probably
a lot more that you can do that
may be specific to the game.
So with Test Lab,
you can run lots
of different kinds of
tests, some of which
are specifically
targeted at games.
One test that requires
little-- well really,
no effort on your part--
is Robo.
Anybody familiar with Robo here?
Yes, all right, we got two.
OK, Robo is a framework
of application crawlers
that are used under
different conditions.
So when Robo sees an opaque
screen, such as that rendered
by, say, OpenGL, or
Vulkan, or whatever,
it will switch to a crawler
called the Enhanced Monkey
Action Crawler.
This crawler today
uses machine learning
to interpret an opaque
screen and identify screen
elements on which it can click.
Now, Robo shows a yellow
circle in the video, which
you can see behind me whenever
it interacts or clicks
with your app, the app or game.
And clicking, as it turns
out, on the Let's Roll Here--
which is what Robo
has decided to do--
is exactly what it needs to do
to get to the actual gameplay
for Mecha Hamster.
Now, this is Mecha Hamster.
Mecha Hamster, I'll
talk about a lot later,
but it's a game that
we built in Firebase.
So Marvin, if we can
switch to the demo.
So I'm going to do
a quick demo of how
you might run a
test, a Robo test,
within Firebase, within
Firebase Test Lab.
So this is the Firebase console.
How many people
use Firebase here?
A few.
Oh, that's much better.
All right, thank you.
So you've probably been
down the left nav bar here.
Under the Quality section,
you'll find Test Lab.
So we're going to
click on Test Lab here.
And we're going to run a test.
So I'm going to pick from this.
I'm going to say, I
want to run a Robo test.
So I'll pick a Robo test.
I'm going to browse for my--
oop, what happened there?
That's interesting.
Let me resize that for a second.
If that's the worst thing that
happens to my demos today,
I'll be happy.
Anyway, so I'm going to click
on this year, which is the Mecha
Hamster APK to upload.
There we go.
It's better.
So now, this is the
Mecha Hamster game.
It's going to upload this game
into a Cloud Storage bucket--
rather slowly I might add.
It's going to upload it into
a Google Cloud Storage bucket.
And then, it's going
to allow us eventually
to pick from a set of devices on
which we want to run this test.
So what we will be
presented with--
and I don't think
we'll ever get there--
but what we will
be presented with
is a list of devices, about 100
or so, of different API levels
that you can choose from.
Now, of course, we have virtual
devices and physical devices.
For the most part, what
we understand from games
developers is you only really
care about physical devices.
So you can pick from the set
of Android physical devices.
And of course, we have lots
of Pixels, lots of Samsungs,
lots of different
devices that you
can choose from-- high-end,
low-end, gaming devices,
and so on.
And I don't think it's
ever going to get there.
So then you pick your locale.
You pick your
screen orientation.
And so since it's never
going to get there,
I'm going to select here
and go to the other thing I
ran two days ago from somewhere
where they had a little bit
more Wi-Fi.
And these are the test
results from that run.
It's a Robo test across
three different devices--
API is level 26, 27,
and 28 on a Pixel 2.
So very quickly, we can take
a look at the test results.
Now, you have full access
to the test results.
There's even a way to
get to the raw test
results, which are just files
in a Cloud Storage bucket.
But we got here various
statistics about the crawl.
We have logs.
We have screenshots here.
It's a Unity game, so
it says that there.
And we'll eventually
get the screenshots.
And of course, we have the video
and the performance metrics
here.
And you can see here the
video, which I'll actually
stop playing here.
The video probably
won't come through.
But you can see that we have
all the different metrics
associated with the video.
And as the video plays, which
it probably will never do,
there'll be a little gray line
that comes across the screen
to tell you where you are within
all of the performance metrics.
So this is very, very important.
And frames per second
here shows you--
the graphics here
shows you there's
a dip here at the beginning,
You may be concerned about that.
But anyway, you've got the
context for the results.
Let's switch back to
the slides please.
With a little bit more
effort, you can actually
record test scripts.
So last year at the Games
Development Conference
in San Francisco, we announced
a partnership with NetEase.
NetEase is one of the
largest games development
companies in China.
They had previously built
an integrated development
environment called Air Test,
which they used internally
for testing their own games.
So at the Games
Department Conference,
they released that development
environment to the world.
They also open sourced a couple
of different testing frameworks
that they use for
testing their own games.
The first is called
Air Test, like the IDE
and involves image recognition.
So you can simply
select an image
that you wanted to
recognize, and then
interact with that
particular screen element.
The second, and probably more
importantly, is called Poco.
Poco is actually built
into the game engines.
So it actually
publishes a hierarchy
of screen elements, which
allows you to interact directly
with the screen elements
from within the IDE
and from within
your test scripts.
So Poco has support for
Unity, and Cocos, and also
the Android framework itself.
So you can record scripts
with a game running locally.
I'll show that in a second.
You can then package those
scripts into an instrumentation
test that you then
are able to run
across a variety of different
devices in Test Lab.
And the great thing about
all these test scripts
is, it's incredibly easy to
go back in and rerecord them
if, for some reason, your
UI or your images change.
Let's switch to the demo.
Marvin, please.
So this is Air Test.
This is the Integrated
Development Environment.
And I have Mecha
Hamster, which is
the game I mentioned
earlier, running locally
on this device here.
I probably shouldn't pick it up.
So what I'm going
to do is, I'm going
to show you how easy it
is to build up a script.
So I can, for
instance, say, I want
to touch this area
of the screen.
And we're going to
use Air Test here.
And it will now attempt
to recognize that image
and click on it.
And then, I can
say, well, I want
to wait for something to appear.
So I'll select
another part here.
So as you can see, I'm
building up a script
by interacting with my
game that I can then
test across this
device running locally
or under this
strangely-named menu
item called Overseas Devices.
I can build this into
an instrumentation test
that I can then run
across all those devices
that I want to run them on
inside of Test Lab-- which
gives you the ability to
write these test scripts
and then test them on the
devices your users have.
Marvin, if we can switch
back to the slides.
And if you want to learn more--
I'll step out the
way, just in case--
these are some links.
There's the GitHub project,
where Air Test resides.
And that's the link for the
way you can download the IDE.
I'll let you take a photo.
There we go.
So the third option that
I'm going to present today
is called Game Loops.
We introduced Game Loops
probably a year and a half
or so ago.
Game Loops provide a
way for you to define
one or more critical user
journeys through your game.
So you could, for
instance, focus
and have a critical user
journey, a Game Loop,
for every level in your game.
Or you can focus on every
character in your game
and write a Game Loop for that.
You can have any number
of these Game Loops
and built into your game.
So Mecha Hamster, which
you can see behind me,
is an open source
game that you can
find on GitHub, which we built
to test out many, if not all,
of the features of Firebase.
So it has real-time database.
It has auth support.
It uses lots of the different
tools within Firebase.
But it also has a Game
Loop built into it.
So I'm going to quickly demo
how we built this Game Loop.
Marvin, if we can switch
again to the demo.
So I may not have mentioned
this, but Mecha Hamster
itself is a Unity game, which
means we built it within Unity.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about how we did that.
So I'm going to put
up some code here.
So the first most important
thing about Game Loops
is that they need
to be declared.
They need to be
declared, in this case,
in the Android manifest.
And you can see a
number of lines here
that's important to highlight.
So you need this part
here basically talking
about setting up the
metadata for the test Loop.
For every test Loop,
need an intent filter
that declares the test Loop.
And that's down there.
So now, you've set
up and declared these
within your Android manifest.
The way we built Game
Loops in Mecha Hamster--
and this is not the only way
you could build Game Loops,
but it is the gateway we
built within Mecha Hamster
and it's particularly easy
to set up within Unity--
is, we have a special
mode of the game that
records all of the
user interactions
or the events with
the game into a file.
So this Gameplay Recording
Enabled equals False.
When we set that to
true, Mecha Hamster
will start recording
events into a file.
We can then take those
events and load them
in as an asset within the game.
And I'll show that
a little bit here.
And then when the game
starts up and it's asked--
this is actually the
Gameplay Recorder Class
that is recorded that
basically records the events
and puts them into a
file, serializes them out.
When the game starts
up, you can test
whether you're running
in a Game Loop,
and then load those assets,
and simply replay these events.
Now, as I say, that's
not the only way
you can build a Game Loop.
You could build out a code
if you wished just simply
calling function after function.
But this is a pretty
easy way to do that.
Marvin, if we can switch
back please to the slides.
And if you want to know
more about Game Loops
and how you might
build Game Loops,
there's a rather long link.
So I've presented three separate
automated testing mechanisms.
So let's talk a
little bit about how
you might use each of
these different testing--
how and when you might use
each of these different testing
mechanisms.
So firstly, I talked about Robo.
So Robo is really good
for testing the preamble
to the game.
So it follows through the menu
items, logging in, registering,
all of that kind of stuff.
It's also really good if you
don't have any tests yet.
So maybe you're starting
off with an initial version
of your game.
You haven't written any tests.
You just want to test it--
first internal version
that you want to play with.
What we see application
developers doing with Test Lab
is using Robo as a last
ditch smoke test signal
before you push to production,
so that you can make
sure by looking at the test
results, looking for crashes,
not responding,
whatever, looking
at the screenshots,
the video, makes sure
that you've not done
anything stupid.
Air Test, what I
presented second, good
for the UI navigation.
It allows you to test
basic gameplay, allowing
you to interact with the game.
Game Loops are really good
for testing the critical user
journeys through your game.
And because it's the
same critical user
journey each time, it's
really good for catching
performance regressions.
So you can show that
your performance is not
degraded in between releases.
And you can look back
over the previous releases
and see how long did
this critical user
journey take to run previously.
And lastly, of course,
we're not trying
to take over all the manual
testing-- at least not yet.
Manual testing is
still really useful
for complex interactions,
such as multiplayer, or indeed
some of the late-level testing.
So as I always like
to say, now, with all
of those tests that you've
written, all you need to do
is upload them into a
continuous integration system.
And every time
you make a change,
you can be much more confident--
we talk about the safety
net here-- you can be much
more confident that you did not
break the game in some
obscure way, which means
that your developers are happy.
They have that safety net.
They know that for the most
part, every change they commit,
they can tell if
it's going to break
the game in some
fundamental way.
So they're happy.
Your users are happy
because they're not
seeing the kind of issues
that you're catching
with all of these tests--
which is, of course,
ultimately what we want.
So in summary,
obviously, I hope you
take advantage of the testing
tools that I presented today.
It's like a given.
These tools allow you to test
with Test Lab across a variety
of different devices,
the sort of devices
that your users are using today.
But I also want to talk a
little bit about the future
because, as we've heard from
so many of you, what you really
need is for us to be able to
test your game as your best
manual tester can.
Now, that's a hard but
exciting destination to reach.
And we hope to see you there.
In the meantime, I wish you luck
building the best game ever.
[MUSIC PLAYING]